-Performing "Nothing Changed"
from their new album,
"Only Built for Infinity Links,"
give it up for...
-Quavo & Takeoff!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Mm-hmm, mm-mm ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Don't nothin' change
but the chains ♪
♪ We on ya head like a bang ♪
♪ All double R's, no range ♪
♪ Big stain came with a name ♪
♪ Got all eyes on my game ♪
♪ Hundred thousand,
kiss the ring ♪
♪ Foreign exchange to change ♪
-♪ Foreign, foreign ♪
-♪ Run it up, that's it ♪
-♪ Run it up ♪
-♪ M&M's, whole tick ♪
-♪ Whole tick ♪
♪ Don't mind if I do it,
I get it ♪
♪ I love my brothers,
I split it ♪
♪ Lil'...mind ya business ♪
♪ 'Cause I got some guns,
they hitting ♪
♪ Trap out the bando,
just choppin' the chickens ♪
♪ And now I'm on top
of the city ♪
♪ Designer mismatching, yeah,
the money do backflips, yeah ♪
♪ I flip the mattress ♪
-♪ Flip it ♪
-♪ I pumpin' my glasses, yeah ♪
♪ I upped the status ♪
♪ Now she lookin'
like an actress, yeah ♪
♪ Big ol' bag,
now we gonna...up magic ♪
♪ And I got a hunnid-round mag ♪
-♪ Shoot ♪
♪ To clear out the madness ♪
-♪ Rahh ♪
-♪ I'm the Huncho to my people ♪
♪ And I cannot go out
the saddest ♪
♪ Don't need no money counter ♪
♪ 'Cause I think my fingers
count the fastest ♪
♪ No, I'm not Bruce Wayne ♪
♪ But I keep the fire
like a dragon ♪
♪ Stackin' up loose change and
I turned the...into a mansion ♪
♪ Brought in a new plane, one
phone call when we landing ♪
♪ The crew came from
the northside of the planet ♪
♪ She see the new chain ♪
♪ She gon' jump
right out of her panties ♪
-♪ Jump out,
out of her panties ♪
-♪ Before the trap
turned golden ♪
♪ I was stacking in the pantry ♪
-♪ Stacking in the pantry ♪
♪ Ain't nothin' Hollywood
but the name ♪
♪ I gotta tell 'em that ♪
-♪ Don't nothin' change
but the chains ♪
♪ We on ya head like a bang ♪
♪ All double R's, no range ♪
♪ Big stain came with a name ♪
♪ Got all eyes on my game ♪
♪ Hundred thousand,
kiss the ring ♪
♪ Foreign exchange to change ♪
-♪ Foreign exchange to change ♪
♪ Fame came with the change ♪
♪ You get a stripe for a stain ♪
♪ You 'bout to crash
out your lane ♪
♪ The umbrella out of
the Rolls-Royce Cullinan ♪
♪ Know it came with the rain ♪
♪ No letterman,
I've been a veteran ♪
♪ Do anything for a name ♪
♪ When you start
getting a lil' change ♪
♪ Watch how your partners
and everything change ♪
♪ And when you step foot
in that field ♪
♪ Make sure you're strapped
and make sure you got aim ♪
♪ My...they shooting to live ♪
♪ I seen some...
they shooting for fame ♪
♪ They don't know
that it get real ♪
♪ That's how you end up
getting blown out ya brains ♪
♪ The money, the car,
the chains, the fame ♪
I'd give up everything
♪ To see my grandma,
just to see my... ♪
♪ The drugs can't heal
all the pain ♪
♪ I get you
knocked off of Earth ♪
♪ You play with my body,
you play with my name ♪
♪ I wet 'em up like he surf ♪
♪ If he looking strange,
I pop at his brain ♪
♪ I'm rocking a watch
with no diamonds in it ♪
♪ It cost me a ticket,
it's plain ♪
♪ I put baguettes in the Patek,
what time is it? ♪
♪ And it cost me a Rolls,
insane ♪
♪ I don't post pics
with sticks and... ♪
♪ That's how them boys
get framed ♪
♪ I been the same since...
when they see me they say ♪
-♪ Don't nothin' change
but the chains ♪
-♪ Takeoff ♪
-♪ We on ya head like a bang ♪
♪ All double R's, no range ♪
♪ Big stain came with a name ♪
♪ Got all eyes on my game ♪
♪ Hundred thousand,
kiss the ring ♪
♪ Foreign exchange to change ♪
-♪ Foreign, foreign ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-Durel made the beat.
I'm-a rock with it.
-Infinity.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]